[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bringing brandel shambly how did we get
to this point randall
well i think
i think it does boil down to just a
simple need for a a regime uh that is
dependent upon one
one commodity oil and has a
particular bent to commit atrocities
wanting to enjoy all the benefits of the
west without
um
extending any of the rights of the west
to their cited century
and i'm talking about saudi arabia and
particularly their leader at mbs
who has committed and continues to
commit numerous atrocities but wants to
hide them
and
and he looks at golf as a vehicle to do
that it's called sports washing simple
uh he's he's had success in formula one
he's had some success in soccer uh and i
think he looks at uh golf as uh
uh it's a it's a lifestyle sport it's a
destination sport it's uh got great
corporate involvement and interest and
it's a great demographic in the game and
it has a great history of tradition and
he looked at it as a perfect vehicle i
think to to sports wash
his atrocities
aren't the saudis an ally
of the united states
yeah look i can understand strategic
geopolitical alliances i mean uh the
united states of allied with stalin in
world war ii to defeat hitler they
allied with mao
after world war ii to defeat and
separate from russia geopolitical
alliances are necessary but individuals
uh
don't need to make any such alliances
that they can take a stand and in
particular golfers golfers are the most
independent athletes in the world that i
can think of they're not beholden to
play where their team plays they're not
beholden to play where the ceo
in the case of formula one says this is
where the races are going to be the very
nature of professional golfers is that
they're independent contractors and they
are paid lavishly the top four
highest paid athletes of all time they
go michael jordan tiger woods arnold
palmer jack nicklaus phil mickelson
who's been bemoaning the fact
that he hasn't been somehow compensated
for his worth in the world of sport is
11th all time he's ahead of david
beckham and kobe bryant greg norman who
has long shuffled off the competitive
coil of professional golf remains the
15th highest paid athlete of all time
ahead of kevin durant and lewis hamilton
why is it these athletes are so lavishly
paid
for a sport that is only marginally
watched and only marginally enjoyed and
participated in around the world it's
because of the integrity uh that golf
has with it it's a self-policing sport
it's because of the demographic and it's
because of the longevity but here comes
these athletes who have the independent
status and the money and the wealth
to be unique in sports and tell
mbs and his thugs we're not going to
participate in sports watching your
legacy
but you look at these players and and it
feels like everybody does have a price
tag or at least you know the saudis
think you might have a price tag you
know tiger is it a billion or jack you
know whatever he's getting uh was
getting offered
um you know does rory have a price tag
he's been saying all the right things
jordan spieth justin thompson i don't
know if they do and it feels like
everybody's taking this let's wait and
see approach
with those who haven't joined yet
but what do you think the grand plan is
of this saudi tour next three years five
years if you were looking at what this
is going to be
well they've been at this for a long
time so
they've been researching and trying to
cobble together this tour now since
2014. so we're eight years on they teed
off today
and if you look at the list of 48
players by my count there was only 14
that the average golf fan would
recognize sergio garcia brandon grace
dustin johnson graham mcdowell phil
mickelson poulter schwartzel westwood
camera okay you add all that up 14
players their average world rank is a
hundred
their average age is 40.
they've combined this year to play in
178 events and they've had collectively
12 top 10 so under
no way no shape or form if you're
watching this are you watching the best
players in the world if this were a
horse race it wouldn't be the kentucky
derby it would be a ten thousand dollar
claiming race uh they paid 200 million
dollars for phil mickelson bill
mickelson is 51 years old 51 his best
golf is so far in his rear view mirrors
be like paying 200 million dollars for a
25 year old seabiscuit to race in
kentucky derby
so what is their goal
their goal was initially i'm sure
because they thought they could buy the
48 best players in the world
and the 48 best players in the world
average world rank would be 24 their
average world rank is a hundredth so
quite clearly they haven't been
successful in buying all these players
rory mcilroy said i can't be bought more
cow thomas
spieth scheffler rom they all said i
can't be bought
you know how much is too much
does anybody really need to
damage their legacy dennis damage their
history
damage damage um
the way they're viewed in the game of
golf by not only
tarnishing their their own legacy but
tarnishing the game of golf because if
you think about the pga tour dan
the foundation of the pga tour is
philanthropy
and they have
so many different programs that look
after the players from health benefits
to pension fund to safety nets and they
have tours for the beginning of a
player's career the prime of their
career in the end of their career now
you compare that to live golf
their foundation is greed and sports
washing and they're buying these players
and they will treat them as a
depreciating asset
these players are expendable to them
they will toss them aside when they're
no longer of further use
so the goal of live golf is clear and
simple it is very transparent
it is to sports watch a legacy and to do
it with a facade of sport
okay
the masters british open the open
championship
uh
do you think everybody's going to be in
conjunction here and just say we're not
going to allow even former winners to
compete at the masters
i think it's likely that
two or three of the major championships
will
will
look at whether or not players are in
good standing either with the pga tour
or a member of the uh one of the major
tours
and then
keep the players from entering these at
usga i thought that they might take a
harder stance
they didn't i think they left it a
little bit open as to whether or not
their stance might change in 2023
but their regs don't preclude a player
not being part of a tour i mean a
45 year old plumber can qualify for the
u.s open and go play and they they their
verbiage was that they pride themselves
on being the most open
of all golf's major champions but it is
phil going to play next week at the open
championship he is yes he is they've
said schambeau is going to play if
healthy enough dustin johnson going to
play patrick reed going to play yeah i
think they'll get in the u.s open i
don't know about the open i wouldn't be
so sure i wouldn't be so sure about the
the masters i wouldn't be so sure about
the pga championship i don't think
that's going to happen and they
certainly are not going to play in the
presence cup
they're not going to play in the ryder
cup
they're not gonna play in the players
championship and these sorts of things
all of the the things that were in front
of some of these players not all of them
but some of these they're just not going
to happen ian poulter is never going to
be a ryder cup captain graham mcdowell's
never going to be a writer cup captain
lee westwood's never going to be a
writer cup captain phil mickelson's
never going to be a writer cup captain
phil mickelson's not going to be an
honorary starter at the masters
and they're not going to continue to
make as phil would phil would have
continued to make 10 20 million dollars
a year
for the next 15 20 years and you know
i've talked to sports marketing people
and they think that's very realistic
that he would have continued
to have that kind of income going
forward for decades i don't understand
dustin johnson's comments when he goes
oh
i was gonna have to play golf the rest
of my life
you know i guess to l have his lifestyle
now i only have to play eight to ten
more years and and i'm paraphrasing here
but
it came off so poorly here i want
somebody to just say the following
brandel
i'm okay with this my conscience is okay
with this i took the money
that's it
nobody's gonna say that but that's
really what this comes down to
yeah dan i i um
i would have a little bit more respect
for them if they did that it seems a
simple thing to say i mean you listen to
the comments
uh taylor gooch when i asked about
um
you know how opaque this was from a
moral standpoint said i'm just not that
smart he said that um and the others
uh
you know they fidgeted and they
they weaseled around and they looked for
the members various members of the live
to sort of break up and stop the
questions from coming because
you know they're sitting on a stage and
they're having to tell a lie
and they know it
grow the game and all that nonsense
they're not growing the game they know
they're destroying the game but they
don't care they they cannot in their
wildest imagination think they're
growing the game
uh dustin's comments
you know look um
you know what would he be worth as we
sit here a couple hundred million
dollars if he wanted to quit golf today
he could quit golf today uh his his wife
is
is going to inherit
uh
you know look
let's hope wayne gretzky lives
you know for decades more but i mean
she's certainly not if she's on her own
she's not going to be destitute uh he
could quit he's
you know this is about well you know
maybe i can get another
200 million dollars very easy without
playing without playing but look he's
he's going to forego most of his
sponsorship dollars um
he's going to forego his reputation
which means future sponsorship dollars
and his legacy and
i know that there are tournaments being
contested in the united states but the
goal of these it seems like is to take
them around
the globe so instead of playing 18
events at home
he's going to play 12 in the middle east
or all over the world
um i think when you add up all the
travel time
and the fact that he no longer is
independent you know look if he wants to
take as he as he
no doubt will i want to take a vacation
to some exotic place spur of the moment
can't do it you can do it on the pta
tour you can do whatever the hell you
want if you play
15 events you can go anywhere do
anything you want to take off for a
birthday or coach a game or an
anniversary no problem but try telling
that to mbs
it's not going to happen good to talk to
you i appreciate your uh your comments
thanks dan i appreciate it brandel
shambly
lead golf channel studio analyst came
prepared as he always does